[Music]
C
live from Beverly Hills California
please welcome the president of the
Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences Janet
Yang good morning from Los Angeles and
for those who are watching around the
world good afternoon and good evening
welcome to one of the most exciting days
of the year the Oscars nominations
announcement
with our membership of nearly 11,000
film industry artists and leaders our
acclaimed film Museum and collection and
our world renowned Awards The Academy of
Motion Pictures Arts and Sciences the
home of global Cinema we recognize and
celebrate all aspects of the film
industry and the diverse talented
individuals who make
movies the Oscar nominees in almost
every category were voted upon by peers
in their Branch actors vote for actors
film editors vote for film editors
costume designers for costume designers
and so on best picture nominations
however are determined by all Academy
members this year we had incredible
voter turnout with ballots cast from a
record-breaking 93 countries today we
are thrilled to announce what our
members feel are the best cinematic
achievements of
2023 and now it is my pleasure to
introduce our hosts who will announce
the nominees actress zasi Bates and
actor Jack
Quaid hello
everyone I am so honored to be here how
about you zasi yeah I'm super honored to
be here 93 countries and standing here
now is such a surreal experience my
little girl self is so excited to be
here honestly my adult self is really
excited to be here so for anyone in the
film industry no matter where you're
from to be recognized by the academy is
a dream come true to be nominated can be
lifechanging so let's get into it okay
for best performance by an actor in a
supporting
role Sterling K Brown in American
fiction Robert dairo in killers of the
flower
Moon Robert Downey Jr in
Oppenheimer Ryan Goslin in
Barbie and Mark ruff
in po
things next the nominees for achievement
in costume
design
Barbie pillars of the flower
Moon
Napoleon
Oppenheimer and po
things the nominees for achievement in
makeup and hair styling
are
Golda
mro
Oppenheimer poor
things and Society of the
snow now this year's nominees for best
liveaction short
film The after
[Applause]
Invincible Knight of
Fortune red white and
blue and the wonderful story of Henry
sugar for best animated short film the
nominees
are letter to a
pig 95
censes our
uniform pashi
Dam and War is Over inspired by the
music of John and
Yoko and now we have the first of the
two award categories honoring writers
first for adopted screenplay the nom
nominees
are American fiction written for the
screen by core
Jefferson
Barbie written by Greta Gerwig and Noah
bomach Oppenheimer written for the
screen by Christopher
Nolan poor things screenplay by Tony
mcnamer and the zone of Interest written
by John hling
and for original screenplay the nominees
are anatomy of a fall screenplay Justine
Trier and Ur
arari the
holdovers written by David
hemingson
Maestro written by Bradley Cooper and
Josh
singer May December screenplay by Sammy
bur Story by Sammy Burch and Alex
mechanic and past lives written by
Seline
[Applause]
song last before our break the nominees
for performance by an actress in a
supporting
role Emily Blunt and
Oppenheimer Danielle Brooks in the color
purple
America Ferrera and
Barbie Jodie Foster and
niyad and dine Joy Randall in the
holdovers congratulations to the
nominees and there are more to come
stick with us we will be right back with
more
nominations
[Music]
welcome back live
welcome back
guys live from the academy in Beverly
Hills where we have the privilege of
announcing the nominees for the Oscars
what an exciting lineup so far what's up
next the nominees for achievement in
music original
song the fire inside from flaming
hot
I'm just Ken from
Barbie it never went away from American
Symphony waji a song for my people from
killers of the flower
Moon and what was I made for from
Barbie next up the nominees for
achievement in music original score
American
[Applause]
[Music]
fiction Indiana Jones and the dial of
Destiny killers of the flower
Moon
Oppenheimer and poor
things and now the nominees for best
documentary feature
film Bobby wine the people's
president the Eternal
memory four
daughters to kill a
tiger and 20 days in marip
pole next for best documentary short
film the nominees are
the ABCs of book
Banning The Barber of Little
Rock Island in
between the last repair
shop and naai and
W for best International feature film
the nominees
are
IO Capitano
Italy perfect days
Japan Society of the snow
Spain the Teachers Lounge
Germany and the zone of interests United
Kingdom and for best animated feature
film here are the
nominees the boy Bo and the
herin
elemental
nimona robot
dreams and Spider-Man across the
spiderverse here are the nominees for
achievement in production
design
Barbie
killers of the flower
Moon
Napoleon
Oppenheimer and poor
things next up for achievement in film
editing the nominees
are anatomy of a
fall the
holdovers pillars of the flower
Moon
Oppenheimer and poor
things and for achievement in sound here
are the
nominees the
Creator
Maestro Mission Impossible dead
reckoning part one
Oppenheimer and the zone of
interests next the nominees for
achievement in visual
effects the
Creator Godzilla minus
[Applause]
one Guardians of the Galaxy volume
three Mission Impossible death Reckoning
part
one and
Napoleon for achievement in
cinematography the nominees
are
El killers of the flower
Moon
Maestro
Oppenheimer and poor things
for performance by an actor in a leading
role Bradley Cooper and
M Coleman Domingo in
Rus Paul Giamatti in the
holdovers Killian Murphy and offenheim
and Jeffrey R in American
fiction for performance by an actress in
a leading
role Annette Benning in
Nia Lily Gladstone and killers of the
flower
Moon
Sandra julier in anatomy of a
fall Carrie Mulligan in
Maestro and Emma Stone in poor
things for achievement in directing the
nominees
are Justine T anatomy of a
fall Martin scor Jessie killers of the
flower
Moon Christopher Nolan offen
Heimer yorgos Lanos poor
things and Jonathan Glazer the zone of
interest and now for our final category
I can't wait let's read them together
the nominees for best motion picture of
the year
are American
fiction Ben lir Nikos pigos Cory
Jefferson and Jermaine Johnson
producers anatomy of a
fall and
Dav
Barbie David hymon Margot Robbie Tom
aerle and Robbie brener producers
the holdovers Mark Johnson
producer killers of the flower
Moon Dan fredkin Bradley Thomas Martin
scorsi and Daniel lupy
producers Maestro Bradley Cooper Steven
steelberg Fred burner Amy dering and
Christy mosco creger
producers Oppenheimer
Emma Thomas Charles Roven and
Christopher Nolan
producers past lives David HOSA
Christine Bashan and Pamela cougher
producers poor things Ed gyy Andrew low
joros Lanos and Emma Stone
producers and the zone of Interest James
Wilson producer
congratulations to this year's nominees
it's been an honor to be with all of you
this morning and to all the nominees as
we say in the biz break a
leg good luck to all the nominees watch
the Oscars live with host Jimmy Kimmel
on Sunday March 10th this year the show
will start at a new time beginning 1
hour earlier at 700 p.m. Eastern and 400
p.m. Pacific on ABC we look forward to
celebrating with
[Applause]
[Music]
you